in this world it's all about style and
style is all about me basically how I
choose to cut my hair or the way I dress
myself or how I would design a gaming
avatar all the way down to the fact that
I have my phone wallpaper match the
color of my eyes right but what about
cars how much can you really do to make
it your own expression of who you are
you know there's lots you can pick from
the dealer the type of engine the wheels
the paint but how much can you really do
to make it your own we spoke to Magnus
Walker the king of car customization and
one of the icons of the new need for
speed game to talk about what it's like
to really make a ride your own hi I'm
Magnus walk up welcome to my garage I
always go with my gut feeling if it
feels right I go ahead and do it I've
never been one of those guys that second
guesses or asks other people what do you
think
people have always been updating or
backdating Porsches because a lot of
parts are interchangeable I think a lot
of people relate to the builds that I've
done because it shows that I'm adding my
personality and character into the car
and I'm not afraid to alter something
from the way it left the factory and I
think that's what separates me from
quite a lot of other people in the
Porsche world but i also think that's
the common thread that connects me to a
lot of other automotive enthusiasts
now grown up as a kid in England in the
late 70s early 80s I watched a lot of
American TV naturally Evel Knievel was a
big inspiration but so too were Dukes of
Hazzard and Starsky and Hutch and chip
so that was sort of how my love affair
with America and especially LA was born
was through watching American TV now
it's probably also where my love affair
with American muscle cars started the
color-blocking for example I'm a big
kind of flat black hugs well a lot of
vintage race cars from that area would
have a flat black coat to basically
reflect the Sun glare off the dash when
you were driving so those are elements
that I've sort of tweaked and being
inspired by an incorporated for my bill
there's something very cool about the
Americanization and stars and stripes
and Captain America and Evel Knievel so
that was definitely a source of
inspiration for me with those colors on
277
people have been hot-rodding cars since
day one I think in a sense some of the
details that I'm building and into my
cars now are hot rod elements the
louvered Declan is really a hot rod
technology moving date leads corrupt
upon cars in the 40s and 50s I see
inspiration everywhere i'm not so Porsha
centric where I'm unable to find
inspiration outside of the Porsche world
so I'd been featured in speedhunters a
couple of times and I was approached
probably about a year ago initially
about being in the need for speed game
one day I was here in the warehouse
alone by myself there was no one here I
literally heard the gate sort of
knocking over there and I go to the gay
and who should be there but ken Block so
he came in we had a little discussion
and I thought well ken block's in the
game I like ken block to be honest
easier inspirational figure to me in the
automotive world and ken Block
essentially was the deciding factor of
me being in the new need for speed video
game I've never been a hardcore video
gamer here I'm in the new need for speed
reboot as one of the five icons in the
game and i am the speed icon and again
I'm sort of an inspirational
motivational character so for me it felt
great to be you know in the company of
ken Block nakaya's on the risky devil
dream team and Hiroshi from Tokyo Japan
I think all car guys like to add their
own personality for me a car is more
than just a vehicle that takes you for
me to be is sort of an expression of
what the owner is about to come and bond
that unites all passionate car culture
people together will speak that same
language and I don't know of a single
mark out there or make of car that
someone's not customizing
to me it's a true honor and a privilege
to all the cars that I own in the garage
it represents to me personal freedom to
be able to customize my own Porsches in
my own way along the way if I've created
a little bit of a following your
signature style even better but that
wasn't my goal people seem to have
responded and related to my
individuality in the builds that I've
brought to the Porsche mark
it's a polarizing thing that I do to
these borchers you either love them or
you hate them but ultimately I built for
myself in the real world same as you
guys will build in the virtual world and
then you need for speed video game just
really you just got to please yourself
and that's what I've always done I'm
sort of done it my way since I was ten
years old living that dream for the
first time with a portion poster on the
wall I haven't changed there may be a
bit grayer that beard maybe a bit
thinner than here maybe a little bit
longer but inside I'm still that
ten-year-old with a love for Portia and
I love for customizing and I don't think
that's ever going to change I'm no
different to a lot of other people a lot
of other than Tuesday's out there that
modify their own cars whether it's a
Porsche or Corvette a Ford Mustang or a
Subaru we're all car guys and we all
like to modify
so according to Magnus who really is the
master of automotive expression and hair
as well customization is all about
expressing yourself on the road taking
something that's well established like a
body shape or a material and changing
that to suit who you are so drew you and
I are going to take a classic 70s
porsche 911 and make it look exactly
like Magnus's 277 Porsche island and
that completely defies the point of
everything Magnus just said about
customizing a car is about
individualization about customizing it
to your own taste for your own
expression we do exactly what he's done
that's completely against the point no
we'll start in the same place we'll take
that 1970s 911 but we're going to turn
it into something that's unique to us
all right okay so first things first
let's actually change the structure of
the car to make sure before we change
any colors or anything else that we've
got it exactly the shape that we want
okay so this is the stock shape at the
moment I like it already but I think we
can do more with it hmm we could jump
into a full body kit which is fine if
you want a quick one stop shop to change
it to something radical like that for
example the rwb or a velt mcgriff is a
jet stream is it's a Japanese movement
by neck I son who n of the icons in the
game and they do this handcrafted
process two Porsches that give it a very
unique kind of feel a lot lower a lot
wider a lot more aggressive wheel arches
their immense yeah looks a little bit
like that 993 gt2 that I've seen in real
life yes as the similar air intake on
the rear wing there it is is a very
unique car but it's one that's already
out there and we need to do all right I
think we need to do our own so yes let's
jump in so let's start at the rear all
right I'll take care of the rear take
care of the front okay I don't want the
full rwb body kit but the trunk lids
does look pretty awesome chocolate is a
no
yes so I'm gonna go with this all right
rwb enormous trunk lid you right over
the intercooler okay yeah so that's a
good start I'd see should we change the
exhausts let's do the exhaust okay so
it's either about the straight out the
back or straight up I'm kind of feeling
these okay done purchase an equip
brilliant right onto the wheels on other
wheels let's go for the rims now what
you're feeling for rooms I still like
the stocky shape of a rim not these sort
of very you know narrow racing wheels
with skinny tires I think something
thick well this is classic ok I'll
that's that's the traditional folk style
wheel yeah that looks nice I think we
can get a twist on that rather than
going full modern okay weird so we're in
the muscle car region but I'm starting
to feel these again I like them I like
that yeah that's a bit different ok ok
let's go with that ok stance all right
very important in how a coral looks all
right do we want it riding high nice and
comfortable or do we want it slammed
right down to the deck well I mean let's
definitely see what it looks like way
down on the floor see i'm actually
already preferring this it looks like
the rwb but without you know it's it's
nice and low it looks like a racer all
the way down on the ground like that but
it doesn't have quite so much drama
going on at the front
now what do you think of this look all
right I think it's certainly getting
there I think it the moment I feel like
it looks a bit like a drag racer my kids
designed go very fast and straight line
yeah and see now this is dangerous what
do we want the rear license plate to say
um well it's not a ghost what's our
custom Porsche calls how bout drag you
know drew and seb let's call it Trevor I
like dreb sir beautiful ok let's sir
should we give grab some color this
gives us a color because I am sick of
this baby puke green ok color wise we've
gone with I guess it started as a
British racing green and ended up in
more of a baja blue I like the bar heart
blue I the racing green just didn't work
with the Porsche at all I think bar
highs it's classic in its own way but
then we design what became I guess the
palm tree on the front which started out
as horns and then became a very slightly
off-center palm tree but we have nodded
to Magnus on the front bumper as well so
we've got his design on the lower part
of the front bumper and we've offset the
color as a as its own thing with the
with the red and the white as well yeah
so the whole front end of a car is a bit
more Magnus and then we go over the top
too not unlike Magnus a union flag on
the roof to the side decals the comments
the comet because this car goes very
quickly like comments like a call it
exactly I see what you've done there I
thought it was a genius design idea they
looked like ice cream cones at first but
then if you look at the most comments
then they're they're actually much
cooler we're continuing around the back
it gets a lot more aggressive with those
massively flared wheel arches yeah and
that rwb spoiler with the air intakes in
it rwb also has some great design work
on the top of it so that everyone knows
is dread this is dreb yeah he is our
ride he is forever drive and then is the
fish also dread the fish the fish is
trying to escape drabs engine bay you
would appear it's not a hospitable place
for fish no no so this is what we've
been able to knock up in just a few
minutes of playing around with the
creation tools and as you can see we
have made it our own imagine what you
could do if you actually had some time
and creativity you could do so much so
very much but I still like our a cross
between the mini and the Baja and the
comet and of course the the massive rwb
racing spoiler it's got elements of all
over you've got Japan you've got la
you've got England and I think all
together it creates something very
beautiful it's ours that's the best I
can savor its destiny hours if nothing
else there we are never going to drive
this down the road in the game and bump
into another one quite like it well
frankly jus I think that dread was not
only a beautiful porsche 911 but also
drove incredibly well and that was
before I even started messing with all
the bits under the bonnet or the rear
bonnet boot bonnet boot the boot bonnet
lip thing yeah now that we only just
scratched the surface of what we could
do with the tools available there is a
vast amount of creativity that you can
put into these cards and it's important
you're going to be taking this car out
and racing against thousands of people
online and you want those people to
judge you by how that car looks even
before you've lined up on the starting
grid so if you really want to let your
individuality shine through there's a
real opportunity here to make every car
in the game exactly your own so if
you're going to race the need for speed
make sure you use the tools available to
you and make your right erode
you